[Music]
all these people interested in stories
is what are your nuts scientists are not
more objective than other people it's
not a question of suppressing emotions
why do we have such a hard time
convincing people of things that appear
to be pretty obvious so you define
yourself as a skeptic or you're one of
the enjoying the skeptics camp how do
you define that and what does it mean
for the way you live your day-to-day
life so skepticism means different
things of different people
it started out actually as a philosophy
of life back in ancient Greece and the
skeptics the ancient skeptics thought
that the way to get a good luck to live
a good life were simply to suspend
judgment not to attach yourself to any
opinion that way I imagine that if you
actually could manage that you have no
political opinions and buddy nobody's
gonna be after you because you're on the
right or the left or the center and
whatever so they thought that this was
the way to to have peace of mind in life
and since they also argued that there
really is no way for human beings to
know and anything for sure then it was a
sort of interesting coherent philosophy
modern skepticism means something
different it is very much related with
to do to the reactions against
pseudoscience it is very much a movement
in support of scientific education so
modern skeptic would be somebody who
ideally at least investigates phenomena
that are outside of the normal pure view
of science you know UFOs astrology
parapsychology things like that things
that scientists themselves probably
won't be bothered to do and with the
intention to figure out if there is in
fact anything behind these things
I prefer to think of modern skeptics as
you know people who are generally
open-minded about the possibility of
paranormal or strange phenomena but that
really want to see the evidence and
seriously look at what the claims are
and and whether they stand up to
scrutiny usually they don't that's the
problem so ie a modern skeptic or an
ancient skeptic I'm a modern skeptic my
philosophy of life is leans more towards
tourism than skepticism in terms of
ancient philosophies I do think the
ancient story at the ancient skeptics
were interesting bunch and they had a
number of interesting points they do
inform mordants skepticism because we do
retain this notion that knowledge proof
is a very high standard that almost the
Islamic almost never reached in reality
even in science you know when people say
oh there's a scientific proof of
something well usually scientists don't
prove things mathematicians are more in
the business are proving scientists can
provide evidence but evidence can be
faulty evidence can be a provisional
scientific theories may may be supported
up to a certain point and then abandoned
so the modern view of human knowledge is
in a sense more skeptical that is we
really are aware of the limitations even
of science all right so what's the
problem that we're going to talk about
in the next community well this is the
simple version of the problem
astrology over here astronomy over there
pseudoscience science if you have
trouble with this I think you're in the
wrong place
okay but that's the problem the problem
is you know how do we tell them
apartment why is it that it's that
increase in some cases we can say yeah
this is really not sign whatever it is
it's not science and in other case you
can say yeah sure of course it is and
then what happens in between are there
situations where you kind of yeah there
you go like this and so you'll see in a
minute there are the second question is
why do we care right what's the
practical import of all of this well I
think there are three major answers to
why we care about what philosophers of
science refer to as a demarcation
problem how to delineate two separate
science from non science and in
particular science from pseudoscience
right but you can see the problem is
actually very old how do we know how do
we trust if you're not a physician how
do you make up your mind about whether
to go to the quack or what other people
say is a quack as opposed to what other
people say is a physician turns out
philosophers have thought about this for
quite a while
one of them is Alvin Goldman and he has
proposed a five-level test for finding a
trustworthy expert I'm gonna walk you
through the five levels of the test this
is very useful if you get anything out
of this talk please get this slide okay
not as it is now as it will develop in
the next few minutes and then I'll give
you a application to a real case okay
this is truly useful you can go home now
from now on and and have a ready-made
tool for determining if you want to
trust somebody who claims to be an
expert or not I'm not claiming
infallibility to the tool but I'm
claiming that it's much better than what
most people normally do first question
examine the arguments presented by the
alleged expert and her rivals that's
great except that this does run into
Socrates problem that is in order to
examine the arguments you actually have
to be an expert yourself if you are
great right so if you are an economist
then you should definitely you know put
your own opinion out there about
economics but not about other stuff if
you don't understand it to look for
evidence of agreement among experts if
there is a consensus among experts
chances are that
your best bet now agreement among expert
doesn't mean that the experts never get
it wrong yes we all know that 500 years
ago allegedly everybody every expert
thought that the the the the the earth
was flat and not round actually that's
not true
astronomers have known that the earth
was round since the ancient Greeks but
sending that as that aside yes the
experts can be wrong even now even a
consensus among experts can be wrong the
question is yeah but have you got
anything better it's it's a question of
where do you put your money okay where
are you gonna bring your money when it's
not a matter of things that actually are
important 3 look for evidence that
expert is he fed an expert when you go
to your doctor you notice I mean at
least in the United States works this
way you have they have a lot of diplomas
on the wall and the more diplomas they
have and the more from prestigious
universities the better you feel about
the doctor right if it turns out that oh
wow she's got a diploma from Columbia
and another one from Oxford it's like
cup this is good if it's got a diploma
from the University or I don't know what
you can wait a minute hold on because
this woman or man no actually what
they're doing so you can you should
check for what are the experts ez fed an
expert you can do that actually fairly
easily these days you can check up you
know on websites the background the
publication records all sorts of stuff
number four investigate what sorts of
biases the expert may have experts are
biased because every human being is
biased
we all have agendas we all have
interests we all have opinions but some
opinions and some biases are worse than
others so if your doctor keeps
prescribing the you the same drug and it
turns out that he actually gets money
from that particular from a suitable
company you might want to ask for a
second opinion okay it doesn't mean that
that's not a good choice because a lot
of these drugs actually do work and they
do what they're supposed to do but you
should be you know inquiring into well
what happens to doctors that don't get
money from that pharmaceutical industry
do they actually prescribe something
else and i'ma fight check the track
record of the expert I mean if he's an
expert presumably was right more time
than not if you go to if you have a
problem with your car you go to a
mechanic but
mechana keeps give you back the car and
it's not fixed at some point you gonna
say you know what I'm gonna look for
another mechanic right the track record
is important financial advisors have an
horrible track record this is actually
established there's research on this
stuff okay they don't do any better than
chance in the long run they may succeed
at one point or another but they don't
long do men and much better than than
than average then random okay so here's
an example should I have action and my
kids and we're gonna pit your doctor
against Jenny McCarthy who is a famous
model and actress who knows nothing
about medicine or at least does not have
a track record in medicine so here's the
have the five criteria for zygoma and
then we're gonna compare your physician
against Jenny McCarthy arguments Jenny
McCarthy argument is my science is my
child which is not a good argument this
is a direct quote that's why it's in
scare quotes you're a physician
presumably even though she does might
not do directory medical research
presumably she keeps up with the medical
literature and knows about ongoing
studies being published about for
instance the vaccine autism
controversion connection is there
agreement among experts no in the case
of Jenny McCarthy yes in the case of
your physician yes essentially anyone
who's done Studies on vaccines and
autism agrees that there is no problem
is the expert an expert no yes so if we
were keeping scores right now we match
were three to nothing in favor your
doctor is there bias well I think in
this case they both could be charged
reasonably charged with biases Jenny
McCarthy of course in she's probably
genuinely concerned about her child that
might be also an effect due to the fact
that you know being famous and having a
sense of a mission in order to help
other people those could all play into
the psychology of the person
understandably but they can bias the the
behavior on the other hand your
physician as I just mentioned a minute
ago possibly gets money on incentives
from Big Pharma and therefore she's also
biased so that's
draw we're still three to nothing there
is no track record here of successful
predictions or or anything about
medicine yes there is presumably a track
record there otherwise she wouldn't be a
doctor and otherwise she wouldn't have
patients so the result is we're counting
four to nothing in favor your doctor
that's a route in football right it's
like okay you're done
so as a modern skeptic and when you
looked at certain ideas that are maybe
not mainstream scientific ideas more
kind of paranormal beliefs or and
reflections of those kind of experiences
was there you said most of them don't
stand up to scrutiny but whether any
bats did that's a good question
historically yes like it depends on how
you look at things but for instance
alchemy is today it's considered
pseudoscience because if you think that
you can actually turn you know lightning
to gold or something like that you're
seriously mistaken but at some point in
the past alchemy was could they take it
in seriously until a few centuries ago
well then he mutated in a sense into
what we today call modern chemistry
right so the alchemists the successful
alchemists became chemists and chemistry
certainly science so that kind of claim
stood up the alchemists actually did
discover things about what we were to
take all the chemistry of elements
although their core idea was in fact
mistaken so there are examples in the
history of science where certain fields
start out in a kind of a sketchy
position and then they either evolve
into pseudoscience they develop I should
say or they evolve into science I mean
think about it the other obvious example
is the fact that until several centuries
ago there was no sharp distinction
between astronomy and astrology there is
today but you know Ptolemy and was just
as much an astronomer as an astrologer
and that went on for most of the Middle
Ages and then only gradually people
realize that there was some good stuff
keep that what we today call astronomy
and some stuff that didn't work out and
that's what we think of astrology even
very famous scientists got involved at
some point or another we what we would
today call pseudoscience I mean Newton
is arguably one of the most you know
famous and you know the geniuses of
science of all time
turns out he spent more time studying
alchemy and doing biblical criticism of
all things than physics but we remind
remember today as a physicist because
the physical part worked and the alchemy
and biblical criticism didn't work so um
are there any contemporary examples from
contemporary science that you think is
more pseudoscience or in slightly
problematic there's a number of areas of
modern science that are problematic but
that's the nature of science I think so
for instance of the search for s
addressing intelligence our safety yeah
it's done by scientists is done by using
very expensive instrumentation you know
radio telescopes usually it's definitely
not a pseudoscience but it's not quite
science is it we don't know we have no
data at all you know we're in found a
single case so far so the sample size is
N equals 0 the theory is a little bit
shaky and optimistic and basically you
said the researchers simply assume that
there are beings out there that have a
similar psychology to our own and want
to communicate with us so it's it's a
little bit uh you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't consider it a mainstream
science it's kind of one of those
borderline cases evolutionary psychology
is another one so the notion that human
behavior evolved is pretty sound that's
part of standard evolutionary biology
but when you try to apply directly
evolutionary theory to modern human
behaviors are such as gender differences
for instance and then becomes much more
problematic because it's difficult to do
the appropriate tests did
data are difficult to gather it's easy
to speculate and to come up with I
father sees that however are not
necessary standing up to scrutiny so
psychology is another one of those
things is right in between and depending
on future development over the next
decade or so we may talk about it as an
established science down the line or as
something that actually devolved into
pseudoscience in less recent but not too
distant past things like eugenics or
phrenology both of those were considered
scientific when they had their heyday
and then eventually you know both of
them were sort of dismissed as not
working and from a scientific
perspective and then if people insist in
in pushing them then that's when the
word pseudoscience comes up
pseudoscience doesn't refer to something
that is wrong to an idea that it's wrong
because there's plenty of ideas in
science like what I would like every
theory in physics before the current one
and probably the current one is also at
least incomplete so in some sense it's
wrong in my current one I mean quantum
mechanics which at the moment is the
most established scientific idea of all
times but physicists already know that
it's incomplete so there that's why
they're searching for the next iteration
so the difference between science and
pseudoscience doesn't lie in the fact
that one is right in the other one is
wrong that's actually a common
misconception both in the public in
general and sometimes even among
skeptics the real difference is in the
methods and the real difference is in
the fact that once you are you get a
negative result you accept it yeah well
okay that didn't work so we're gonna set
it aside if there are negative results
showing very clearly and consistently
than an idea didn't work and yet the
proponents of that idea insist that it
is a good one that's when they begin to
slide into pseudoscience I mean
pseudo-scientists they don't use that
term but pseudo scientists have the same
trappings of science they published
journals they have conferences you know
they look at empirical evidence
sometimes you do statistical analysis so
from the outside - a person doesn't know
better they it looks like they're doing
science but if you're doing
that kind of things with a notion that
it's been clearly discredited then that
to me is that arguably the best
efficient pseudoscience why do we have
such a hard time convincing people of
things that appear to be pretty obvious
such as astrology doesn't work vaccines
don't cause autism brexit the better the
upside that was I didn't mean to get
into politics okay why well I think that
the answer comes all the way back from
Aristotle I just saw the wrote a book on
rhetoric rhetoric has a very bad sort of
reputation these days like it's what
lawyers do to convince people of things
that are not true but in fact rhetoric
is the art of persuasion if you're
talking about talking to other people we
actually want to persuade other people
and Adi städel studied this in quite a
bit of detail and he said there are
three components to actually be
persuasive with somebody else
one is what he calls the logos you have
to have your facts traits straight and
your reasoning correct because otherwise
you're sophist you're just selling a hot
hair okay you have to have the stuff
right now
most scientists and science popularizers
stop there that's the only thing they
get when they talk to other people when
they write for other people when they
are in the Bates or things like that
that's the only thing they care I got my
facts straight and got my reasoning
correct that's it
every sensible human being should
therefore be convinced they apparently
don't know anything about human beings
because that's not enough to convince
people what else is necessary the ATA's
you need to establish your trust and
your authority and I don't mean by that
just oh I got a PhD that's you know lots
of people have PhDs that's not enough
you have to establish your trust with
the people with the audience that you're
talking to okay back in Tennessee years
and years ago I did a number of debates
against creationists and one of them do
English I noticed started out a debate
by talking about the local football team
and the local quarterback American
football I said what the hell is he
doing he's wasting time precious time
he's not putting forth arguments or
facts on behalf of his position he was
establishing
thus you say you can trust me you I'm
one of you guys I'm talking your
language
politicians do that all the time
unfortunately most politicians don't get
the logos correct and finally pathos but
does means emotional involvement you
have to make people understand that this
stuff actually matters to them directly
if you make the wrong decision about
vaccines your kid is gonna die or it's
gonna get sick
okay or your friends kids are gonna die
or get or get sick it has to matter
otherwise people don't see the relevance
to this thing
unfortunately pathos emotional
involvement is anathema to scientists
scientists are trained as a career to
stay as much as possible away from
emotional involvement and that's their
big mistake so in order to in fact talk
to people in a reasonable way you have
to have all three components I started
was right and a lot of the problem that
we have even individually I'm not
talking just about scientists see when
when you talk to your friends or your
relatives is that often you use
arguments and facts but you neglect the
other two or you downplay the other two
and you're not getting anywhere with
that
[Music]
moving on to stoicism um how did you
turn towards this philosophy as a kind
of philosophy for life midlife crisis
which I'm told pretty much everybody
goes through at some point or another
yeah I was appearing in life where
things were going not too well
personally and and even from the point
of view of of my profession it it seemed
like I had hit a little bit of a quiet
zone where yeah I was doing my job and
was doing fine but it wasn't anything
that was particularly novel or exciting
or something like that so those are the
period in life for you sir if you can
afford it you can stop and think about
stuff and saying hmm
what am I gonna go from there now since
I was beginning to study philosophy
professionally because at the UH Patel
up until that time I was actually a
professional biologist I switched to
philosophy and about that time once you
start studying philosophy at the
graduate level in that in my case but
even I think at pretty much any level
you can't avoid start thinking about
sort of the big picture and saying you
know you read Plato for instance or you
read a book on ethics or something oh
that's interesting where do I fit in
with this so that kind of started a
quest to explore different possible
options and I looked at in a number of
possible philosophies of life the
philosophy of life by the way it's
nothing mysterious it's just a
combination of two things a metaphysics
and an ethics a metaphysics is a base
essentially an account of how the world
works and ethics is an account of how
you should behave in the world if you
define it that way then every religion
is also a philosophy of life right so I
grew up Catholic for instance and you
know Catholicism is gives you
metaphysics it tells you that the world
was originally by a God and God decides
what goes on in the world that's a
metaphysics and then it tells you you
know an ethics it tells you you go to
church on Sundays because you want to
learn how to be gay be a better person
right so those two character
six are common between you know among
all religions and philosophies of life
so I looked at a number of them explored
them including Buddhism including at two
or three different ancient Greek Roman
philosophies and I was in the middle of
this thing and then one day on Twitter
of all places I saw this thing that said
help us celebrate stoical week I said
what the hell is stoic week and why
wouldn't anyone want to celebrate it
I remember the Stoics from from high
school but I didn't really remember much
about them other than they're supposed
to surprise emotions and go through life
with a stiff upper lip which turned out
not to be true those are both
stereotypes but hey that's what I
remember but I was curious so I signed
up turns out that stoic week is an
annual event which happens every fall is
organized by an international group of
scholars philosophers historians and
cognitive behavioral therapists because
it turns out that stoicism has actually
has influenced the development of CBT in
the 1950s and 60s so there are certain
kinds of psychotherapy that actually
originated at least with inspiration
from the from the Stoics so I didn't for
a week it really clicked it's in like I
started reading the historic sand I
started practicing you know their
meditations and their exercises and you
really collect so I committed for
another couple of months until the end
of the year and then I committed for end
of the year and then here we are five
years later I wrote two books about it
and all these people interested in
stoicism what are you nuts
the Epicureans are meeting around the
corner by the way ah all right they have
free drinks now just kidding so first
the basics stories started out about the
near the end of the fourth century
before the modern era in Athens the
guide that established the philosophy
was Xena of sytems you know was actually
a merchant and he lost everything that
he had in a shipwreck right outside of
Athens he made it to the city and of
course what would be the first thing you
did if you just lost everything in life
you walk to a bookstore that's what he
did and if you walk to a bookstore what
happens well you obviously you hear the
owner of the bookstore reading out a
book about philosophy and in particular
in depth in that case the memorabilia
which is a book by example about the
life of Socrates so Zeno God like it was
very interested and he asked the
booksellers is like where can I get me
one of these meaning a philosopher and
and the books bookseller said over there
there is one just walk in mind because
that was ancient Athens Athens you know
people were walking behind him chances
are that they were philosophers the guy
in question it's a different world you
know it was a different world the guy
question was credits of t-base it was a
cynic philosopher cynicism doesn't mean
what I mean didn't mean what it means
today in fact many interesting English
words cynic skeptic stoic and epicurean
don't mean what they meant in ancient
Greece and that that could be a whole
interesting talk right there but I'm not
gonna do it now so Xena started studying
first with credits then with other
teachers and eventually he felt
confident enough to sort of start
teaching on his own and he started doing
that in public in a place called the
store película which means the painted
porch right in the middle of the market
near the Agora in central Athens and
that's why the philosophy is called
stoicism because he started out in the
store so stores are where public markets
public colonnades where people would
gather so stores is in from the
beginning was forward to people was they
were interested in talking to the people
they were just walking by as opposed to
most of the other schools which
established themselves in the suburbs
outside of Athens so that they wouldn't
be bothered by you know people unless
they were really interested so that's
how it started
the basic assumption of stoicism is that
we should live life according to nature
now before you run into the forest naked
and start hugging trees that's how many
means there's nothing wrong with doing
that if you want to do it go ahead but
but that's not sources living according
to nature means
we should take seriously human nature in
order to decide what kind of life you
want to live because otherwise we are in
fact human beings we're not lions we're
not chimpanzees were not something else
so there are certain things that work
for human beings because of the nature
of humanity or what it means to be human
now of course different people have
different ideas about what it means to
be human the old concept of human nature
is been under discussion in both science
and philosophy for literally 2,000 years
the Stoics had this notion however that
there are two fundamental components to
being human that Trump everything else
one is the where eminently social
animals were not the only social animals
obviously there are social other social
primates that are social insects and so
on but we are fundamentally social we
can survive on our own if we have to but
even for long periods of time but in
fact we thrive only in social groups we
seek recognition we seek affection we
see relationships with other people so
that is that is a fundamental component
of a good human life the second thing
that distinguishes human beings is the
ability to reason to a far greater
extent than any other species on earth
we can have a whole separate discussion
I'm a biologist we can have a whole
separate discussion about the extent to
which other species are capable of
reasoning or not but hey it's just us
here there I don't see any chimpanzee is
discussing philosophy at the moment so
we definitely have an ability to reason
far above em beyond anything else on
planet earth now whether we use it well
and we use it often that's a whole
different thing but we are capable of it
so from those two things according to
the Stoics it follows that a good human
life a human life that is worth living
that the Greek word is eudaimonia is
made up is consists of using reason to
improve society so to be helpful to
other people and to yourself by applying
your ability to reason okay so that's
pretty much what stoicism tries to do to
improve people to make people better
using their reasoning abilities and you
use them not for their own selfish
motives but in order to make everybody
better to make the place the planet a
better place the notion is that because
we're so interdependent whenever you
help other people you're helping
yourself and whenever you try to become
a better person you're automatically
helping other people around around you
what's one of your dearest
rules or idea historic ideas that have
really helped you the fundamental one
that has made a major difference in my
life and it does affect the life of
pretty much anybody who practices
tourism is something called the
dichotomy of control
the Stoics believe that everything you
do can be partitioned in two components
one part that is really up to you where
you really have control and another part
that you then it's not up to you what
you don't have control because of
complete control because the outcome
depends on on external factors and a
fundamental tenet of stoic philosophy is
that you should focus all your energy on
the parties under your control and then
develop an attitude of equanimity toward
the second component sometimes you win
sometimes you don't but it's not a
reflection of who you are it's a
reflection of the fact that the universe
works in you know strange ways so I may
give you a specific example let's say
that that tomorrow you're up for a job
interview and you know the normal thing
to do would be to to be anxious and say
you know I really want this job and I
I'm really gonna help then I get it and
so on that's normal the stoic would
approach in this way it's like well
tomorrow I have a job interview did I do
everything that is my power up to this
point to prepare for the interview yes
and my focus for at the beginning of the
interview yes do I know what I'm talking
about yes that's it done then how the
interview goes it's not really up to you
it depends on your competition it
depends on who the interviewer is you
know whatever whether you got up in the
morning and
we're now in a strange mood or whatever
and the fact that even if you get the
job you shouldn't according to the
statics you shouldn't feel too cocky
because part of it is a result of your
efforts but part of it is you just got
lucky
and similarly however if you fail if you
don't get the interview you shouldn't
beat yourself up because again it's now
under your control you did if you did
what everything you could
that's that's all that's all that it's
under your control so that really does
help I think that essentially it in
modern terms is the the basic notion is
to internalize your goals so I just
mentioned the job interview let's say
that you know a common thought is if
you're in a relationship I hope she
loves me know I hope to be a loving
person because that's under your control
but if she loves you back it's up to her
oh I hope that this friend is gonna you
know really be a good friend well you
can be a good friend that's I'm under
your control whether other people are
going to be different to you or not it's
not and so on and so forth so you can
apply it pretty much everywhere and once
you start practicing that way and thing
looking at things that way you just calm
down because you say well I'm gonna
accept whatever happens so long as I
know that I've done the best that I
could two final questions so does that
mean that basically I have a continuous
dialogue in your head so one voice is
the kind of anxious irrational voice
saying oh my god but I really want this
interview and then the stoic within you
says you've done everything you could is
that what happened that's pretty much
that's right and in fact that's also a
technique that he's using in County
behavioral therapy to challenge your own
thoughts challenge your own perceptions
Epictetus was one of the major historic
philosophers from the second century and
he has this beautiful way of expressing
these thoughts he said that we should
look at our impressions and impression
in stoic terminology is your initial
opinion about something
so for instance that oh my gosh should I
have the interview and this is stressful
this is a stressful stress that's any
that's an opinion that that's expressing
an opinion or who
expressing the opinion the interview is
just a fact of life it's not the
interview doesn't come with opinions you
are expressing that opinion and so you
can challenge yourself and say wait a
minute why am I thinking this way why
why not
try to think about things in a different
way and that actually does work there's
pretty good empirical evidence that you
you know it's not a silver bullet so
it's not like you start doing this
tonight and all of a sudden your life is
fine but if you do it on a regular basis
you learn to challenge your own
impressions your own opinion your own
judgments then little by little you it
will become easier and easier and at
some point you stop having those kind of
distressing that's where the stereotype
of the lack of emotion comes from it's
not a question of suppressing emotions
it's it's a question of controlling and
interacting with your negative thoughts
[Music]
so my position is that first of all we
should ask separate questions one is
there really a problem to what really
the problem is and three do we have some
reasonable scientific ideas as opposed
to non scientific ideas for solving the
problem and so the first thing is you
know do we have a problem maybe it the
fine-tuning problem is is often posed in
terms of well isn't amazing coincidence
that we have all these constants that
just happen to produce a universe like
the one that we have where complexities
arises and where life is rising and and
then of course our life we're here
discussing philosophy and physics I
think that a better way of phrasing the
problem is actually more basic which is
we don't know where what constraints if
anything the fundamental laws and
constants in physics that is the real
question I think that the entropic part
of it is a destruction and frankly I
guess I'm like yeah I do think that it's
a destruction that comes out of the fact
that we but got these cosmic sized egos
as human beings like like or it has to
be about us for some reason I think it's
a it's really misleading way of putting
the
question the real question is you know
we have laws of physics we have a number
of parameters that seems to be fixed
within those laws why why is it that
they have those particular regardless of
whether those particular parameters then
bring about almost a pians or dinosaurs
or whatever it is I mean this is a world
mostly a bacteria so one could actually
reasonably argue from a biological
perspective that is all fine-tuning was
so the bacteria can have a feast on
planet Earth right so that's the first
the first issue that I think that we
should really get away from these
entropic stuff altogether the second
issue in terms of well so why do we have
these these parameters that are that are
set this way somehow one possibility is
that the god stuff as you say that's
clearly metaphysics of a particular type
of the theological metaphysics there are
actually other options even within
metaphysics that don't require sort of a
transcendental God there is the
simulation hypothesis for instance this
is the idea that we're all playing in a
video game actually all characters in a
video game and somebody set up the
parameters of these video game the laws
of physics and and the fine-tuning stuff
it's actually really the parameters of a
video game and somebody's doing this
thing and there's actually a really
interesting argument for why this is not
as crazy as it sounds although that to
me doesn't sound that different from god
because after all a video gamer who is
capable of producing the entire universe
and I can't distinguish that from God
and then there are Saudis the yeah and
then there are these these scientific or
at least scientific sounding answers
that we're going to get into in a few
minutes and there the question is you
know really is it science or how much is
it science or how what is our hope to
make it transition from interesting
speculation to to actual science but I'd
like to also eventually get to this
point in the discussion and say when we
say that these parameters are fine-tuned
or however you want to you want to put
it we're sort of making an assumption
that the parameter space is in fact
essentially infinite and flat that is
the dispute
these parameters is in fact nothing like
a bell curve or a very very spiky
looking thing it's just flat and goes on
forever in other words that really I
don't know the gravitational constant
let's say in theory could take any any
value whatsoever so if that's true then
the probability that it that it would
take that particular value is in fact 1
over infinity which is negligibly small
and therefore land now we have a problem
but we don't know that we don't know
from what distribution this statistical
distributions or underlying
distributions these variables in this
parameter is actually taken from for all
we now it could very well be that there
is only one possible value for for these
parameters well may be that there is a
small number of values or maybe the
distribution looks something like you
know a triangle like this or whatever
we have no idea and of course one of the
things that physicists have been trying
to do for a while coming up with a
so-called theory of everything which is
another example of large egos at play
it's precisely to that to tell an answer
to that question right so oh actually as
it turns out these primaries cannot take
all you know an infinite number of
values they can only take a certain
number of values and if it is a small
number of values then it's really no
longer a particular surprise or a
particular miracle that we got what we
what we got so we don't have any answer
to those kinds of questions now we're
going to hear about a couple of answers
of possible answers now but when you go
through this process I think you should
still keep in mind a what the real
question is which is the particular why
do we have the laws of physics basically
that we have and B that perhaps we're
just starting the whole discussion from
it from on the wrong footing that is by
assuming that it could take that these
numbers could take any value 1 in fact
it might not they might not
[Music]
the the first thing I want to make clear
is for myself at least as both
philosopher of science and a scientist
this simply is no such thing as science
without empirical evidence now in
particular we can discuss what is the
relations between empirical evidence and
theory we can discuss whether you know
at one point a theory becomes not
particularly interesting as a research
program because it's not yielding
anything that can be tested all those
things can be negotiated and they need
to be negotiated by the properly
competent scientific community you know
I'm a biologist I'm not gonna tell the
string theorist well you've waited long
enough dudes move on right they're gonna
be the ones to decide when that time has
arrived but I think that it is simply
non-negotiable that empirical evidence
no science without empirical evidence
and there's no science more particularly
without a good match between the
empirical evidence and the theory but
that's one of the things that probably
will be to have to flash up now often we
have this issue of Oh scientists or some
scientists at least are dogmatic well
yes and no there's two ways of looking
at the issue of dogmatism here on the
one hand there are certain things that
have been so well-established and so
well understood that yeah I'm gonna be
demanding about it if somebody tells me
you know Darwin was fundamentally wrong
natural selection is not a real process
in nature I'm just not even gonna look
at that person because that is something
that has been established over 150 years
plus experimental results theory and so
on and so forth I'm simply not I don't
have the time to renegotiate okay but if
you're telling me well I don't think
string theories will establish them sure
of course yes that's true and in fact
the relevant epistemic community that is
this fundamental theories themselves are
actually not in agreement on what's
going on there so I'm gonna wait until
they figured it out so that's one sense
in which scientists can be dogmatic the
other sense is science scientists can be
dogmatic in the sense that they can be
resistant to new ideas and sometimes
improperly so or maybe they be they can
push their own agenda their own ideas
and in a way that it's inappropriate
well welcome to the world I mean
you know scientists are human beings
whatever makes anybody think that
scientists are different you know
qualitatively from the rest of humanity
I mean that's that seems to be a
mistaken idea scientists are not more
objective than other people they're not
certainly not more you know somehow
capable of deciding what that's what the
truth is about their own theories they
have their own biases we all will go the
way of whatever science works and it
works reasonably well at least we
haven't figured out a better way of
investigating nature so far is that
science is done by a community of people
and these people have the more varied
their cultural background gender
politics and whatever it is the better
science comes out just to give you a
trivial example until not that long ago
a lot of medical research was done you
know only on middle-aged white men
because the people that were doing the
research were middle-aged white men then
it turns out that certain aspects of
human physiology are in fact
significantly different for women or
it's infinitely different for people
with different ethnic backgrounds but
that came to the fore and was corrected
only once we started having enough women
or enough ethnic minorities involved in
the process of science and people start
looking and saying wait a minute you'll
be singing or half of the picture you're
missing a quarter of the picture that's
the way work we don't we figure out a
better way of doing it yet at the moment
it's science the only path to knowledge
that depends on what you mean by
knowledge I think it is the only path to
serious understanding of the natural
world i we don't have any other way we
haven't figured out any other way of
doing it you can try mystical insights
just sit in your room and think about
the universe and you won't come up with
anything worth coming up with I am a
philosopher I can do a lot of armchair
philosophizing but I will not be
discovering new facts about the world
that way
however if by knowledge he means
something broader like understanding
because as has just been pointed out but
uh you know it's one thing is the fact
and the other thing is the understanding
of those facts the theories are actually
supposed to articulate an understanding
of things so understanding is broader
than just than just science so we can
have other disciplines contributing to
an in particular in this case I think
philosophy and philosophy of science
epistemology even cognitive science
because cognitive scientists are the
ones that actually point out the
cognitive biases the scientists
themselves suffer from as human beings
and therefore can be addressed finally
are there limits to science because
sometimes you hear these these old thing
about well but science is a limited
enterprise yes of course it is it's a
human Enterprise it's done by fallible
human beings it's done by human beings
that are smart but up to a point we can
understand process information and so on
and so forth the only opportunity to a
point there a certain way and not only
that but we are clearly defined in our
in the way in which we think by our
particular cultural background and
historical moment okay
the reason both Darwin and Wallace came
up with with the metaphor of natural
selection because the theory is as far
as we can tell correct and it describes
the way the world is but then the
metaphor of natural selection came out
of the specific background of Victorian
England okay it's it had been done at
another time in another culture they
would have come up with a different
metaphor of a different way of looking
at things that's true everywhere all the
time if anybody including any scientists
think that they can transcend their own
cultural milieu they're just fooling
themselves for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute's arsine ideas her III TV
[Music]